so what is native script native script
is a free and open-source project you
can find it on native script org and
this is the official positioning
statement right so whenever you create a
product you have to have a positioning
statement how are you how are we going
to communicate some people let this
thing is so everyone sits around in a
and a marketing meeting which is like an
eight-hour ass-kicking and then at the
end of that you get something that looks
like this that everybody's supposed to
go out and repeat but this is terrible I
don't I don't use this somebody in our
community came up with this which is a
lot better native script is a runtime
for building and running native iOS and
Android apps from a single JavaScript
code base that's all it is it's exactly
what native script is now if you've done
any native or mobile data before the
wheels in your header probably already
turning and you may be thinking wait a
minute I've heard this before I have
heard this song before and it's it's not
a great song I really like it and it's
not PhoneGap it's not quite obvious that
ionic it's not a webview all right so
there's no webview in these apps none
whatsoever
so you have real native components as
opposed to like an HTML button or an
HTML slider or some CSS style equivalent
which is an imitation of a button but
not actually a button it's actually
something in a webview
so these are real native components
there's no Dom in native script for you
to manipulate so you can't do document
dot get element by ID because there is
no documents there's no HTML there's not
HTML but there is a markup language what
do we call that anybody XML so we call
it market we don't call it XML it is XML
XML is has a terrible reputation leave
the saying is XML is like violence if
it's not working you're not using enough
of it all right XML is a terrible
terrible thing that was thrust on upon
us by Java really it's a way to
communicate data it's terrible for
communicating data but that's not why it
was invented it was invented for
documents it's great for marking of
documents when you're marking up a
visual interface you are marking up a
document so we use XML for the interface
so the way that it works and the way
that it's different from hybrid or
Cordova ionic PhoneGap is on the right
you have
and what a Cordova application and I'm
saying ionic because that's kind of
ubiquitous but the web browser the your
code runs in the web browser which then
has some sort of limited access to
native api's well native script just
runs directly on the operating system so
you have access to all ApS anything you
can call anything from JavaScript
anything that's on the device can be
called from JavaScript you can think of
it as like node for mobile is actual v8
or JavaScript core runtime engine that
sits on the mobile device runs there and
it'll actually create native apps this
is not xamarin xamarin cross compiles
while depending on what you're using iOS
or Android or forms cross compiles or
has some sort of abstraction there's no
cross compiling in native script the
code that you write ends up on the
device not cross compile to something
else as JavaScript on the device there's
a hundred percent direct access to
native api's when xamarin written has a
release they wrap every single API now
they're really really good about it
they're really good about it
in fact they release it on the same day
that new @ SDKs and API is a release but
they do write and abstract every single
API native script does not it does not
because it doesn't need to
you have full hundred-percent access so
that means if you were to add an
additional SDK or library to your
application it's immediately available
inside a native script just as it would
be with native code and there's no net
ok there's no c-sharp anywhere in here
this is not react native how many people
have heard of react native but to be
fair it's really really similar to react
native both of us are using JavaScript
virtual machines bundling those
delivering them to the mobile device the
difference is in the case of react
native there's a couple different
distinct distinctions here the first is
you don't have to write any objective-c
Java or Swift in native scripts ever
because all you have to write is
JavaScript the second thing is you have
a hundred percent direct act to access
to native API if you notice I've said
this like five times now because this is
one of the most important things about
native scripts
so we really when we think about native
script you think about that as something
that is really trying to fulfill the
promises of hybrid apps hybrid and we
would say hybrid we mean PhoneGap
Cordova these things hold so much
promise because it allows us as
developers to take our web skills and
immediately be able to build mobile apps
hybrid is amazing because you can build
your app in like an hour two hours tops
and you've got an app and it looks like
an app so 80% of your dev time is
finished in like the first hour two
hours and then the next 80% of your dev
time is spent trying to figure out why
buttons don't accept clicks why does my
ListView jank when I scroll why does the
screen flicker why does this not show up
at all on some older versions of Android
if you've ever done hybrid dev you know
exactly how this feels
and what do you do you blind yourself
there must be something wrong with me
and then you get on Twitter and you see
all these tweets from very smart folks
at Google that are telling you to open
the developer tools figure out how to do
perf analysis you can do this right it's
your fault that the app is slow it's not
your fault that the app is slow the
webview is slow and your feet are tied
and you're gonna have a really hard time
being successful so these are the
promises of a hybrid that native script
aims to fulfill the first one is that
you can build native mobile apps with
your web skills we see if I can play
this here so this is an app this is our
showcase app that you can download from
the App Store using your web skills
JavaScript CSS yeah frameworks like
angular these things should work inside
of native script and they do the second
one is reuse your code across iOS
Android and web one project that can
reach multiple destinations in this
example we have on the Left we have the
web in the middle we have Android on the
right we have iOS now of course you
would never do that because this apps
responsive and would be fine on either
of these two screens but if you wanted
to you could and this is the direction
in which we're moving that you should be
able to have code that runs on multiple
platforms and Java scripts the only
language that's going to take you there
let's see there we go and then lastly it
has to be performant really really
really perform it because mobile devices
have really performant ass
excellent apps right it's not the
desktop mobile apps we expect them to be
performant and if they're not the user
blames the device they'll say my wife
does this all the time she'll open up an
app and she'll be scrolling through a
mobile web page and if it has a lot of
ads it'll just stop scrolling or it'll
just stop working what it'll just go
blank and she'll say there's something
wrong with this phone there's nothing
wrong with your phone there's something
wrong with the person who decided to
send you 27 megabytes of ads when you
were trying to read an article so the
idea is that that shouldn't matter for
the user it should always be performant
so we create our own benchmarks here you
can see benchmarks against xamarin and
then against native Android as well so
our goal is to be as fast as is humanly
possible for mobile devices so you have
a couple different architecture options
when you're doing native script you can
do straight JavaScript yes 506 you can
use typescript anybody using typescript
in here ooh that's not good cuz you're
about to see a lot of it before people
okay
yes six yes five yeah I quit sure that's
fine what about let's see what about
react developers angular just pulling
the crown backbone knock-out rolled my
own built my own created my own wheel so
you can also use angular as well and
well if we have time we'll talk about
this how angular works with native
script but you can use angular 2 to
create native mobile apps and angular 2
is really cool because when they build
angular 2 it took him a really long time
to get it finished but one of the cool
things that they did was they decoupled
the renderer from from angular 2 so
angular 2 doesn't really care what you
eventually used to render the
application most of us think of the
browser's being the only render but it's
not and so native script can come in and
say okay now I'm the render not the
browser but me and you can actually
render you're saying angular 2 apps into
native script sounds kind of crazy
we'll talk about there in a second and
if we have enough time we'll do some
demos you can also use pre-built code
you can use modules off of NPM because
just JavaScript as long as there's no
browser dependency in your JavaScript
it'll work so moment J s works great
jQuery not so much because it depends
heavily on a Dom that isn't there you
can use anything from Android Arsenal if
you've done native mobile dev you know
that you have to have these third-party
open source components that other people
have built because simple things are not
there like a pull to refresh on a
ListView in a mobile app doesn't exist
out-of-the-box in iOS need to plug in
for that and same for Android now you
can write your own or you can go out to
the Android Art Arsenal or cocoa pods
and you just download someone else's
there's like 20 to choose from it's
fantastic
this script allows you to reuse anything
that you can find on those two you can
drop it into your native script app and
you can immediately access it with
JavaScript
lots of integrations we integrate with
visual studio code we've got a plugin
for that we've got a plug in for
webstorm we talked about npm cocoa pods
and Gradle or Android Arsenal and then
we have over almost 400 plugins now for
all sorts of different things on NPM so
all of our plugins are delivered via NPM
native script itself is an NPM package
which you download and install in the
news that screenshots little ole there's
like roughly 400 now all right so I've
made a lot of really crazy claims so I
want to talk about how this actually
works because it sounds a little bit too
good to be true so we're gonna look at a
couple different drawings here and then
we're gonna actually look at some demo
code and I'm gonna do some live coding
which any very experienced and good
speaker will tell you you should never
do but I am neither of those things so
those rules do not apply to me because
this is the way this works you have a
virtual machine either v8 or JavaScript
core v8 for Android javascriptcore for
iOS and in that VM you write your
JavaScript so in this case we're saying
bar switch equals new switch now what
happens is there's another layer that
sits the next one down that contains a
switch module so once you drop into that
switch module the switch module then
goes into the native script runtime
which didn't renders you a switch on
either iOS or Android so you think about
it this way if you were gonna create a
switch in iOS you would do this you
would say you I switch
Astra's on/off equals and then this
crazy bracket syntax right this is
objective-c to create a new switch which
you would init with frame cg rekt 0 holy
crap
nobody in here wants to do that right me
included so what we do instead is
basically we say your code becomes this
in native script this code right here
gives you the exact same thing but you
just write it in a descriptor we back up
a second this is the Objective C this is
what you write if you were writing it in
native script now that looks very
objective-c ish right it does because
the API is are the same we're not
changing the api's we're just
translating everything so that you have
a bridge to call these things from
javascript but then we provide a layer
of abstraction as well and that's where
that new switch comes in so you don't
even have to do this new UI switch we
take care of that under the covers we
wrap those components for you alright so
with that I'm we're now have any more
slides that's it I just want to do some
coding I want to show you how this
actually works and this is the app that
we're gonna try to build today again we
don't have as much time as I thought we
did but we'll see how far we can get we
have create a reddit reader we're gonna
read from the off thread which is have
any other fellow editors in here yeah if
you don't use reddit you should it's
like Facebook just without all the crap
you don't want to see right it's like
everything good from Facebook without
all the nonsense so we're gonna create
this reddit reader that pulls in a feeds
we review an HTTP call and then we're
gonna display each post inside of a
webview and we're gonna navigate between
two views this is very simple but it
also allows us to do some very
fundamental things like how do I use a
ListView how do i bind today to how do i
make an HTTP call how do i navigate from
one page to another these are
fundamental things that we have to know
first all right so with that here we go
let's hope this isn't thirty minutes of
demo fails all right so I'm gonna bring
up my command prompt here and remember I
said native script is an NPM package so
you can install it with npm install g
native script and that will install
native script now i don't need to do
this because i've already installed it
so what i'm gonna do is just TNS which
is short for to Larrick native speakers
so just TNS is the shorthand just
remember that you can
I doubt native script if you want to but
that's if you want to be long-winded
that way that's your call so we're gonna
do a new app and we're just going to
call it let's call it reddit Mobile and
then I'm gonna specify a template
there's different templates that you can
specify and I'm gonna use tight script
sorry for those of you who didn't want
to see typescript you're gonna see some
typescript I promise it won't be bad you
might even like it by the time I've done
and what this is going to do is it's
going to create a new application for us
so that app was created by a native
script and then we're gonna change into
that directory here it's gonna do to the
reddit mobile directory and then what I
want to do is I want to load it up on my
emulator so I'm just gonna do TNS live
sync iOS emulator and we'll watch it now
what this is gonna do is it's gonna do a
bunch of stuff in the background so it's
gonna fire up the typescript compiler
and it's gonna fire up the the bundler
and the Builder and then it's gonna fire
up the directory watcher so anytime we
make any changes to the project in the
code
it'll be immediately reflected in the
emulator so we don't have to go through
that build step every time a stop start
stop start which kind of sucks and so
once this build the first time takes a
little bit longer
once it builds it's it's quite fast now
while this is happening let's open this
thing up and look at the code anybody in
here using Visual Studio code now that's
a lot of hands that makes me happy what
up what about what what else is there
sublime text Adam it's a big one Visual
Studio anybody
Wow several Visual Studio folks any
Eclipse people oh yes that's the best
thing I've seen but five years ago you
asked this question and like heads would
go down and how through it would be like
even Android developers don't have to
use Eclipse anymore they gets using
Android studio jetbrains is doing some
amazing things with their IDs webstorm
the IntelliJ platforms good good stuff I
highly recommend that you check that out
so once we have our app open here we've
got a bunch of different files here and
the first thing that I want to do is
kind of clean this up so if I go over to
here to code preferences workspace
settings to collapse the sidebar let's
just do a files exclude and these are
all the files that thinks I probably
don't need and it's right but
let's instead exclude all the JavaScript
files because we have typescript which
is going to transpile to JavaScript you
don't need to see both of those files
and then we get a map file for every
JavaScript file as well which we also do
not want to see because it makes the
editor really busy so once I kill these
things here and come back you see we
have a lot less files over here which is
nice so what we have here is a main page
and there's a lot of comments that comes
in here by default so we'll take some of
these out as we move through we
basically have one function that
specifies a page and then specifies a
binding context for that page now that
page is right here main page XML when
you have it in native script you have an
XML file and then you have a JavaScript
file of the same name and those two
things are automatically matched
together so when you're using the main
page XML if you specify main page
JavaScript that's your code behind if
you will
any old web forms developers in here we
had a code behind file or Windows forms
same kind of concept here right some
people have them like twitches and
post-traumatic stress disorder from
their old SharePoint days anybody here
recovering from SharePoint I actually
got my start as a SharePoint developer
straight out of the gate and I was like
this is terrible people do development
for a living oh gosh this is I hate this
so bad it turns out I was just terrible
at SharePoint okay so we have this
navigating to method you can think of
this as like your page load in any like
if you did web forms before you'd have a
page load event so this fires when the
page is loaded and then we have some
layout components here they're gonna
look pretty proprietary because they are
remember there's no HTML so it'd be
disingenuous for us to say hey create a
div and then in the background we do
something totally different right are we
like hey create a you know oh whatever
and we'll train don't worry about that
it's HTML but it's not really HTML and
so what we do is we actually create our
own components so we have different
kinds of layouts you'll see these today
we're basically gonna use stack layouts
and grid layouts but there's also rap
layouts and absolute layouts and dock
layouts basically the UI components that
you're going to need to build your
application and when people are learning
native scripts one of the hardest things
for people to learn is this markup and
so
once this is probably the the biggest
learning curve once you're over this
it's a whole lot easier alright so what
happens here is there's a label and
actually let's go over and have a look
at this application see we can tap this
button here and this is this right here
this mark up renders that UI and you see
there's an on tap and a message and
there's a view model over here as well
and the view model contains some
constructs that we're gonna use but for
the sake of time and because there's a
lot of code here that's gonna look
pretty busy I want to take all this out
here and well actually let's take out
most of it so we're gonna leave
observable in observables there are
implementation of an object that you can
assign properties to and read from and
when you update it updates the UI and
vice versa so this is that whole and
medium binding thing that everyone's
become quite familiar with so what we're
gonna do here is we're just gonna create
a class called VM which is going to
actually view model here which is going
to extend and observable and inside of
that let's create a constructor there we
go and then we have to call super all
right so that's the bare bones of what
we need for this thing to work
now what I want to do is I'm gonna come
back here might create a message
property on my class here and we'll just
set it to hello November excellent so
I've saved this I'm gonna come over here
to my XML file and you can see that
there's a message here and see this
binding syntax is double curly braces
that's how we bind to properties on the
view model and then if you remember over
here we didn't call ours ours wasn't
hello world view model we called ours
view model so let's change this we'll
call this the view model let's see here
go back to my I mean I'm not exporting
got export it's this is what's so great
about typescript is that it tells you as
you go along we're gonna making stupid
mistakes so now it's coming in and then
we'll change this as well so we've made
these changes and now if we go back here
and make sure we're still live syncing
on this side our application is up and
you can see it now it's displays hello
November right because we change that
property and then we assign the view
model to the UI and bound those two
things together so now that we've done
that we can start to create this
application now that we've got the glue
so let's go back here and go to the main
page and I'm gonna take out almost
everything in here pretty much
everything in here and instead what I
want to do is I want to create a list
view all right so let's do that now if I
do that in nothing else and we come back
to the application here you see that we
have a blank screen and that's because
we have a list view but there's nothing
in it and because there's nothing in it
stack layouts by default have a height
of 0 they expand to the height of the
content well there's another component
that we're going to use that has Ellen's
and Rose if you don't specify columns
and rows it will actually expand to the
height of the screen and that's called a
grid layout so let's go back here and
add in a grid layout save that and now
we have a list - you see it's empty this
is a UI tableview this is a native
ListView all right this is not an
unordered list that's going to bite you
later on this is the real deal the super
optimized component so now we want to
put some data on this super optimized
component let's go over here and let's
make an HTTP call from our view model
where is it there we go let me collapse
this and we can import an HTTP module
and actually from HTTP and I can say
Star as HTTP from HTTP all right so this
is our HTTP module that you're getting
used to make your your a jet will call
them Ajax calls your remote data calls
so let's come down here and create a
function where we can actually do this
so we'll create a function called we'll
make it private and we'll just call it
get posts ok and inside of this function
we're gonna do HTTP GET Jason right I
bet you can guess what that does and
because we're not on the web we can call
a just a standard JSON feed and that's
totally fine we don't have to do JSONP
or anything like that so let's do we can
do HTTP and I think it's reddit / r / Oh
Jason
the reddit API is a lot of fun to play
with because when you find a specific
feed that you like you can tack Jason on
to the end and it just gives you the
Jason right like no authentication no
pomp and circumstance just data which is
great perfect for demos and then that's
gonna return a promise and inside of
that promise we're gonna get a result
and we'll specify that result can be of
type any and this is really just two
please type script
we say any we're basically telling
typescript like just leave me alone for
this object it does what I say it does
and then inside of this we want to pull
in and actually build up an object that
we can create but in order to do that we
need a collection that we can put those
things into that can be bound to the UI
so I change this to be posts and what I
want to do here is pull in another
construct that we have that's called an
observable array so let's go here and
say observable array - array we have now
we have an observable array two types of
observables and you've seen them
observables that's hard to say and
you've seen them both write an object
and a collection observable observable
array that's it now you know everything
there is to know about observables
all right so inside of our class here
we're going to say our posts is an
observable array and we'll say it's of
type in E and then down here we just
want to start adding things into that
array when they come back from the HTTP
call so instead of you guys watching me
do this let me come over here and pull
in some code here and just copy this up
and paste it in and we said this was
result but we're calling it response ah
there you go gonna get there I swear
alright so at this point we basically
have gotten a result back we're mapping
it into these objects which were then
pushing into this post collection here
so the next thing we need to do is on
the constructor I just want to call this
method so I can just call this get posts
right here and before I forget I'm also
gonna have to say this stop posts which
is right up above us equals new
observable array okay basically you have
to new up one of these things before you
can use it if you try to assign to it
before it exists nothing happens alright
so we've got this we're calling this
let's go back here to our main page and
actually create the markup that we need
to bind to this thing so we can come in
here and say that we want to bind our
items to if you remember we call that
collection posts and inside of our
ListView we want to have maybe a couple
different things in order to have
something in a ListView you need to have
a ListView item template defined
all right let's do this and we'll close
it off here and then inside of that I'm
just going to add a label component and
I'm gonna sign the text value of that
label to title I think is what we called
it over here so let's go back and have a
look yeah so we're we're pulling in a
title a thumbnail the user that posted
it the amount of votes that it has and
then the URL so that we can navigate to
something alright so if we've done all
of this correctly we should actually see
items in the ListView so let me jump
over here and there we go so now we're
pulling back items from Reddit and
they're being displayed in our list view
here and get out of the way control
center alright so the next thing we need
to do is add an image to this so let's
come back here and add an image in so we
can say image and we can say source and
we're going to assign it to thumbnail
I'm gonna come back here and I'm gonna
put these things in a stack layout
native script requires that there be
only one root element in templates so if
you have two root elements like that it
will it will air out and since I know
that's coming I'm just going to avoid it
let's save this and let's come back over
here and the other thing we need to do
before I forget is you have to define a
static width and height for images
otherwise they will have a height of 0
and width of 0 so let's come back over
here and you can see that we have
nothing we have basically the space
reserved for the image but the image
isn't showing up why is that well if you
come back over to the terminal you can
see it says let's see here if we go back
up at transport security has blocked a
clear text HTTP call basically you can't
just call HTTP HTTP from inside of iOS
you can turn that restriction off though
which is what we're gonna do so let's
come back over here and let's go into
app resources and this is interesting
because you can notice here we can get
right at the info.plist now this is
something that you probably wouldn't
necessarily monkey with but if you're an
iOS developer you actually use this
thing a lot it's a configuration file so
we can come in here and we can say let
me grab my snippet here where's my code
box bring your code box allow unsafe
HTTP so we're just gonna copy in this
key there we go and then when we do that
if you come back over to the terminal
you'll notice it tells us we can't live
sync you change the info.plist so you
need to rebuild so we'll just do a TNS
run iOS okay
so because we're running out of time
here we're a little short we want to
kind of jump to the end here what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna copy in a bunch of
markup for our main page it's gonna make
it look more proper let's come over here
and do let's see here page of the styled
ListView that's what I want I'm cheating
hope you guys will allow that let's come
back over here to main page and we'll
just copy this stuff in and then we'll
collapse this we got a lot of markup
here we have a grid layout I'm
specifying two columns this is right
here this is basically saying the first
column is 100 units wide and then star
means the rest and then when we say rows
we're saying Auto just take as much
space as you need and then we're styling
these things with CSS classes there's a
CSS file in this project and we can
style things this way we've got our
image we've got a stack layout with a
label we're concatenating two different
fields right here inside of our binding
expression these are polymer binding
expressions so you look up the polymer
documentation same exact binding
expressions so with all this done let's
come back over here this should be
running again you notice we're now
getting our images in because we've
allowed this unsafe HTTP which is nice
so let's go back here and I'm gonna kill
this and I'm gonna do a live sync one
more time and then while this is running
here let's create a new file that we can
navigate to so let's go to details and
create a new file called details XML and
we'll drop it right in here and then
let's get our details mark up here there
we go
put that in here and then we also need
some type script to put in our matching
details file and we can do that as well
so let's do paste this in and we'll save
it as inside of app as let's see here
details ts okay so let's save this file
save our XML file and then let's come
back over here to the main page and
you'll notice that for our ListView here
we have items and then what we want to
do is when we tap on one of these items
will say item tap we actually want to
show
tails is the name of the function that
we're going to execute we come back to
my main page here and let's do export
function show details and then in our
show details we're gonna pass in an Arg
object so let's say our selected item
equals our exact index so the index is
the index of the item that we select and
also because we don't want to new up
items and assign them at the same time
let's just do a view model equals a new
view model here and we'll just go ahead
and then come down here and say VM save
this and then we can actually get this
post from the amount of post that we
have over here so posts dot get item and
this will get us the item by the index
so this returns us the correct item and
then we can navigate over so I'm I'm
moving really fast here and so what I'm
gonna do is jump to the finished product
since we sort of run out of time I'll
put this on github so you can see what
we're doing here but this is right here
we're basically navigating to any of you
and that's what I would have done next
here so let's jump over and just take a
look at what this looks like here I'm
gonna go back and let's do I think this
one will work oh that's adorable all
right so that's what the finished the
finished app looks like and you can see
we were building up to this but we have
an app when we click on one of these
things the whole screen flips around and
then we can load we're loading this
thing in a web view on the other side
which is really neat because it allows
us to load any sort of content and so if
you have something like a gif for a
video that's embedded in imager because
everything on reddit is imager pretty
much except for everything I'm clicking
on now URI signature mismatches you can
display like videos and gifs um things
like that which is really really nice so
you can use web content inside your
native apps ok so since we've only got a
few minutes left let's do a couple more
things so we did talk about angular way
back like almost we'll see what was the
day yeah February of 2015 almost two
years ago now the angular team reached
out to me it was like hey we see what
you're doing native script do you think
that it would work well with angular 2
and so we spent a lot of time working
with angular 2 and it was it was
interesting it was rewarding it was
super frustrating because they rewrote
it like a billion times from the time
that they first contacted us but we're
really really happy with where it ended
up we're glad that we stuck around you
don't have to use angular when you use
native script but of the couple hundred
thousand developers that use native
scripts half of them use angular 2
that's a lot of people and so we and
we're seeing a growing amount of people
that are using angular 2 as well so if
you're using angular 2 know that you can
also build native mobile apps with
angular 2 and this is sort of the de
facto way to do that if you're on the
angular side so for more information you
can go to native script org I'm sure you
all are very good at using the Internet
you don't need me to tell you there's a
big getting started button right there
when you go there and if you click
getting started it will take you to a
tutorial and you can choose regular
vanilla native script which is what I've
been doing today or you can choose
angular 2 and if you don't know angular
2 and you think I'm stupid because I
don't know angular 2 you're not nobody
really knows angular 2 even me I've been
doing it for a while now and I still
don't really understand it that well but
once you start doing it you do start
enjoying it and we'll teach you angular
2 along the way so if you're interested
in learning angular 2 it's a great way
to learn angular 2 as you go along and I
do think if you haven't tried angular 2
I'd give it a shot I've really enjoyed
it it's very powerful and it does allow
you to reuse your existing code between
web and mobile apps so I think with that
we're right at our 35 minutes here that
was your quick intro to native scripts
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
[Applause]